peut être plus chaud encore en 60 ans de
carrière
monique mercure est devenue une actrice
de référence celle que tous admirait si
les gens dans fait c'est une légende qui
malheureusement vient de disparaître
est-ce que les mises en livre ici dans
les années 70 que ce soit dans mon oncle
antoine de claude jutra ou dans la
comédie érotique deux femmes en or de
claude fournier monique mercure crevé
l'écran comme ça pendant quelques
journées thème satio est une femme de
musées que nos soldats était cultivé
passionné et elle avait tout un
caractère est maintenant j'aimerais tant
des poings par travail aux gens comme
tout le monde à qui reviendrait à les
dompter cracked peuvent le plan
exigeante la force de son jeu dans le
film
j am heart et photographe lui a valu en
1977 à cannes le prix d'interprétation
féminine
une première pour une actrice québécoise
c'est moi qui le triplé jeux la vraie
saveur rejaillit sur tout le québec tous
y mangerez comédienne et surtout et
québécois elle vivait son personnage se
dire que quand elle était osé mais elles
étaient pleins d'autres musiciens de
formation
monique mercure avait aussi une diction
parfaite et c'est donc aussi illustré
dans une centaine de productions
théâtrales dont la deuxième mouture des
belles soeurs de michel tremblay
blanchette n'accuse maintenant
légendaire ces actes chèques sont à
claudine allauch ne m'en ont une espèce
de pezens fun
triste féministe en plus de cumuler les
rôles forts elle a fait rayonner l'école
nationale de théâtre dans les années 90
en donnant plus de place aux femmes
elles étaient je dirais vraiment un
miracle pour l'école nationale de
théâtre et monique mercure c'est
quelqu'un qui n'avait peur de rien ni de
personne
infatigable monique mercure a aussi joué
au petit écran et encourager de jeunes
talents à la fin de sa carrière
on l'a vu dans providence et mémoire
vive
la télévision lui donner avec mémoire
vive providence un nouveau souffle une
visibilité qu'elle n'avait pas jusque là
une forme de popularité qui le musée sur
les réseaux sociaux
toute la classe politique lui a rendu
hommage visiblement monique mercure nous
laisse de précieux souvenirs pour ça que
j'ai fait une actrice pour être heureuse
ici louis fait depuis mai radio-canada
mots rien